Lopez keeps her mouth shut pocket 7s
[Applause]
Bayliss the Simmons way 151 or not guns
inside and beat with the block he's one
of the top shot blockers in the game
Simmons the other way the break
yourself or try to establish locals
dominance for the Brooklyn Nets and
again we talked about new
again points in the paint la plana front
of family and friends and her old
teammates sitting through the nice cook
remember he's left-handed
that was his right-handed hook
[Applause]
[Applause]
no he did
Ben Simmons is out here just putting on
a clinic with the basketball and one and
how about this the wrong don't ask
behind the back peek at the future the
NBA teams with growing young talent like
this get and rejected by Simmons shot
vodka three bar over he comes right here
I mean that's great timing you think he
is beat off the dribble by Ingram I mean
that is met five and five and B with ten
inches inside
[Music]
another as if by jiminy play there for
the Laker Simmons and Kuzma Covington 30
good seconds
[Applause]
so there's the three rebound Covington
off to Ben Simmons - right there another
rebound for Simmons at seven working on
a triple-double 8.7 rebounds with their
biggest lead of the game 16 points
Redick defended by call milk low key
ranch Luke Walton 109 and game indeed
had 46 points 15 rebounds there Simmons
- easy you basketball against each other
man they didn't plan concealer poison so
like five six years old isn't shot
points for the Lakers tonight plus 24 of
the third highest growing bench in the
league Simmons and bead free to fire two
three trying to stop a five-game losing
streak coming in in December last year
they wants 50 to 70 back-to-back threes